tu appelles jacques couilles et la wii
c'est la cas de notre cousin autrichien
et c'est une plaie mois sanitaire c'est
votre famille qui débarque un grand
colosse est un petit jeu lent qui pue ça
laisse une couille
je suis chaque oeil la fripouille les
gars points d'eau qui court dans la
baignoire
du coup il est revenu pour nous faire
chier gavoille ampoules électriques nuit
jour jour nuit mais [ __ ] y'a rien ces
niçois marot c'est de la merde à ce
royal enfin une épreuve
il nous faut remettre le dauphin sur son
trône alors je ne veux pas jouer les
rabat joie que veux tu laisses ucu ce
n'est pas gagné quand on se chauffe au
comptant ont pu la merde probert on est
à table
c'est un festival j'ai en tout cas plus
la grosse chose à la loi j'ai jamais
sentie sein de mamie au menu trois puces
et la vienne